i'd like to introduce our speaker today
once again i'm jackie peterson and i'm
the program manager for the genetics and
genomics program here at the stanford
center for health education i want to
thank you all for joining me in our
fantastic speaker today
today i have professor ami bhatt with me
amibad is an associate professor at
stanford university in the departments
of medicine and genetics
a physician scientist with a strong
interest in microbial genomics and
metagenomics she received her md and phd
from the university of california san
francisco
she joined the faculty at stanford
university in 2014.
in addition to carrying out research at
stanford university professor bot has
active collaborations worldwide
including in nigeria and south africa
she co-founded global oncology and
serves as a director for global oncology
for stanford's center for innovation in
global health
her team's research program seeks to
illuminate the interplay between the
microbial environment and host clinical
factors in human diseases
her laboratory study strain level
dynamics of the microbiome to understand
how microbial genomes change over time
and predict the functional output of
microbiomes
she is keenly interested in how microbes
talk to one another and to host cells
and how to leverage this understanding
to improve health and treat diseases
thank you for being here and i'll now
pass it over to dr both
thank you so much for the introduction
and thank you all for taking the time to
spend an hour with me today thinking
about the microbiome i want you to take
a look at this photomicrograph what is a
photomicrograph a photomicrograph is
basically a microscopic picture that one
can take
what do you see
and what do you think you're looking at
well for me what i see is an incredibly
complicated set of communications that
are going on
this happens to be the cross section of
a colon the colon is the largest part of
our intestine it's at the very distal
part or the last part of our digestive
tract
and what it has is on the right side of
the picture in the bottom right hand
corner these blue stained nuclei that's
actually the host side of the colon or
the colonic tissue itself this happens
to be from a mouse but a human colon
would look very similar
on the top left hand side of the image
what you see are a lot of little little
tiny dots and rods and spirals
these are bacteria this these are the
bacteria that are absolutely teeming in
our intestines
and between the two you see two
greenish layers they're slightly
different from one another and these are
the thick and thin layers of the mucus
this mucus is made by the host and
separates bacteria from the host but as
you can tell if you take a really close
look at that mucus you can see tiny
little bacteria that are actually
invading that
demilitarized zone
so we know that we are covered in
microbes filled with microbes and that
they are incredibly important to our
health
and over the course of the next 40
minutes or so we're going to talk about
some of the things that we and others
have done to investigate this incredibly
interesting relationship
now i would argue that microbiome
science is actually a really old field
even though many of you may think of it
as kind of a johnny completely
in fact if you take a look at this text
from about 30 in the comment before the
common era this was written by marcus
barrow who was writing books on
agriculture
he noted that certain minute animals
invisible to the eye breed there and
born by the air reach the inside of the
body by ways of the no mouth and nose
and cause diseases which are difficult
to be rid of
this is i think actually the first
description in the literature that we
know of of
bacteria and viruses
tiny little animals that we can't see
that can move from place to place and
when transmitted can cause problems
but it really wasn't until the late
1600s and early 1700s until we really
had a better understanding of what these
microbes actually were
pictured on the left here is anthony van
leeuwenhoek he was a famous draper and
nobleman in europe
and what he was really interested in
doing was figuring out the weaves of
different cloths
now as you know when you're weaving
cloth the more threads you have in a
small area the better the cloth and to
be able to assess how many threads there
were in a given let's say square inch of
cloth anthony van leeuwenhoek had been
playing around with trying to develop
better and better ways to magnify
the drapery
and what he ended up doing was actually
developing what we now know of as the
light microscope
now having this cool tool he decided to
not only look at drapery but also at
other interesting things around town and
so he ended up looking at pond scum he
looked at the gunk that was in between
his teeth remember that this was in an
era before common dental practices
and what he found amazed him he found
all kinds of different organisms big and
small rod shaped circular spiral
some were sedentary some moved
and he described these as tiny little
animals again or animal cules
pictured on the right are actual
drawings that lone hook draw drew of
these different bacteria that he was
seeing
and i would argue that this was actually
one of the first times anybody ever saw
a bacterium with their own eyes
of course over the subsequent years
especially in the 1800s people started
to be able to culture bacteria they
could get bacteria put them on these
petri dishes as you see on the left and
grow them up into numbers in the
millions and billions and even trillions
they then would take these bacteria put
them on a glass slide and stain them
with different stains and what you see
on the right side of this picture is a
gram stain which is a classic way to
describe bacteria some of you who are
scientifically oriented in the audience
may know that we describe bacteria as
being staining gram-positive or
gram-negative
and so for a long period of time this is
what bacteriology was all about we
collected samples we cultured them on
special media or these petri dishes we
then put them on slides stained them and
described how they looked under a
microscope
but of course our ability to enumerate
microbes was limited at that time we
didn't know how to grow all bacteria we
didn't know what they like to eat some
of them are totally interdependent and
therefore can't be separated from one
another and some of them don't even
stain with these specific stains that we
had
and so a huge revolution in the field
arrived with the advent of next
generation dna sequencing where suddenly
instead of describing a bacteria by
looking at how it looked in terms of its
shape and its staining we were able to
sequence all of its genetic code or dna
in a's c's t's and g's
and then describe the
or the words of dna that we found in a
given sample
in so doing we were able to not only
measure one bacteria at a time that we
could isolate in culture but without
having to isolate and culture bacteria
at all we could read all kinds of little
words and then assign them to different
bacteria
now this revolution really only started
in
in real zest about 20 years ago
and at this point our field is centered
around this central type of approach
we collect stool samples from humans or
other animals we can also collect other
types of samples where microbes live
such as the skin the mouth the nairs
we then extract dna from that sample
and then we
analyze the sequencing data that we get
or all of the different dna words that
come out
and we try to ask questions like who's
there in this community
we also want to be able to ask what are
they doing and what do they make
to analyze these huge amounts of data
that we're able to generate now we
obviously need efficient ways to analyze
this big data
and for that reason we and others
develop computational pipelines that
enable us to turn
billions of pieces of information into
orderly graphs
so over the course of the past 20 or so
years the microbiome field has learned a
lot
we know that we have microbes all over
our body
we know we have lots of microbes in our
mouth
our skin the colon and the vagina for
example
we know that as pictured here the
bacterial types that are present in
these different communities are
different
and they're not only different within
our bodies but our mouths are very
different from our spouse's mouths or
our kids mouths and so we know that the
microbiome varies a lot from individual
to individual
by the numbers we know that we have
approximately 10 trillion microbes in or
on our bodies
they can make up up to 3 percent of our
body mass
and there are at least as many microbial
cells as there are human cells in our
body
so i would argue that we're almost equal
parts them and us
we also know that there are 10 to 100
times as many microbial genes as there
are human genes in a given human
which suggests that if we take a look at
this from the standpoint of genetic
diversity that is contributed to our
bodies
bacteria do a lot more of the heavy
lifting than our own cells do
but do these bacteria viruses fungi etc
really make a difference in our health
the answer to that is absolutely
scores of studies have demonstrated that
my bacteria that live within the large
intestine can do a variety of different
things such as extract nutrients from
our food
this is certainly true for us where it
is estimated that about four percent of
the nutrients that we absorb into our
bodies are actually not digestible
initially by us but rather pre-digested
for us by our bacteria
but it's even more true in animals like
elephants which are pictured here
elephants and other ruminant animals
such as cows as you probably know are
entirely herbivorous so they eat plants
and plants are really hard to break down
their fibers are very complex and
mammals don't actually possess a lot of
enzymes that enable us to break apart
these complex fibers which are sugars
stuck together in a long chain
elephants actually depend on bacteria
that live within their guts to do some
of that heavy lifting
and you might ask yourself well how did
those bacteria get there in the first
place
well
it turns out that baby elephants have to
eat the poop of adult elephants within
their herd to essentially inoculate
their guts with these bacteria
it's been nicely demonstrated that baby
elephants that are kept away from other
adult elephants actually runt which
means that they don't grow properly
probably because they're not able to
extract enough nutrients from their food
nice research in animals has also
demonstrated that you can not only lose
weight because you don't have the right
bacteria in your gut if you're an
elephant you can also gain weight if you
have let's say the wrong bacteria in
your gut if you're a mouse
in very nice research that was done by
peter turnbull when he was at washu st
louis he and jeff gordon demonstrated
that if you fed skinny mice poop from
fat mice
that was actually enough to make them
better at extracting nutrients from
their food and make them fatter
now of course this is very compelling
it's been followed up with interesting
human studies and this finding hasn't
recapitulated well in humans to date but
it's certainly a nice example of how our
bacteria are doing a whole lot more than
just hanging on for the ride
beyond extracting nutrients the gut
microbiome can be incredibly important
for regulating metabolism
producing important vitamins like b12
for us
and even regulating immunity
indeed we know that over the first
approximately three years of life the
microbiome and our adaptive immune
system meaning our b cells and our t
cells actually co-develop
and early microbial exposures in kids
probably have a large role in shaping
the immune systems of these children
this has been well demonstrated in
animal models and we know that animals
for example that are born germ free or
without any bacteria actually have a
whole host of immunological deficits
now your early life isn't the only time
where you can affect your microbiome we
know that dietary choices throughout
life dramatically impact the gut
microbiome
be it from formula versus breast milk
cumin breast milk actually contains a
large variety of human milk
oligosaccharides once again
oligosaccharides are like fibers they're
chains of sugars put together
and it turns out that these human milk
oligosaccharides are not digestible by
you or me they're actually only
digestible by certain bacteria that live
in the baby's gut
and so the gut microbiomes of babies
that are formula fed are actually quite
different from the gut microbiomes of
babies that are breastfed
there are also choices that we make
throughout life that continue to impact
our microbiome for example pictured here
are onions
onions or alliums which is what the name
of the family is contain a huge amount
of fructooligosaccharides again another
type of fiber that can actually change
the composition of the microbiome
what we know is that the microbiome
changes over time
and that from infancy to childhood to
adulthood when people start to
experience diseases the microbiome can
shift
we know that all kinds of things ranging
from solid food feeding to having
diseases such as obesity or diabetes can
impact the gut microbiome quite
dramatically
and so in our lab what we are keen to
understand is how we might be able to
save cancer patient lives by
understanding and manipulating the
microbiome
in particular in our lab we focus on
hematopoietic cell transplantation or
hct
as many of you know hct is a therapy for
people with refractory or relapsed
leukemia and lymphoma it can be a very
effective way to treat very aggressive
blood cancers but it comes at a high
price
it's a complicated therapy that involves
blasting people with anti-cancer drugs
or chemotherapy plus or minus radiation
we give them so much of these dna
damaging agents that they're rapidly
dividing cells including
all of their progenitor blood cells
which are called hematopoietic cells
actually can't recover well
so what we do is we get hematopoietic
stem cells from a donor and introduce
them into the patient
those hematopoietic stem cells will
eventually take take hold and they will
differentiate into red blood cells white
blood cells and
platelets now while transplant is an
incredible therapy that has saved a lot
of lives it turns out that it has a very
high mortality rate as well
in fact about 20 to 30 percent of
patients who receive a hematopoietic
cell transplant actually die in the
first year after their transplantation
and what was really alarming to me was
that only about a third of these
patients 37
die of a relapse of their original
cancer
which means that 63 percent die of
treatment related complications
of which infection is actually a big
part of that pie
many of these non-cancer outcomes that
happen to our transplant patients that
cause death are associated with changes
in the microbiome
as indicated here by the asterisks
and so the open question that our lab
tried to tackle a few years ago was how
does the microbiome impact infectious
complications of hematopoietic cell
transplantation
it seemed reasonable to think that since
we have so many bacteria in our gut
maybe those bacteria were impacting
whether or not people got infections
after transplant
this work was done as a collaboration
between tessa anderman a former
immunocompromised host infectious
disease fellow in my lab and fiona
tamborini a former graduate student in
my lab
and what we focused on was trying to
bring precision clinical microbiology to
the table in the sequencing era
so this starts with a case
at stanford we actually saw a patient
who was a 39 year old woman with a b
cell acute lymphoblastic leukemia
she underwent a transplant and was
actually doing quite well unfortunately
37 days after her transplant she
developed fevers and chills
and a blood culture showed the growth of
the bacterium staphylococcus at the
dermidus
our question was where did this
infection come from
tessa and fiona knew that many gut
microbes can cause infections for
example e coli
but staph epi as the name implies is
actually usually a skin commensal
meaning it lives on the skin of people
however in looking at gut microbiome
data from many of our patients the two
of them had noticed that organisms like
staph epidermidis while very rare in the
gut microbiomes of healthy people like
me
can actually be quite prevalent in our
transplant patients probably because
they've been exposed to a lot of
medications that can alter their
microbiome
and so tessa and fiona asked the
question is the gut microbiome a
reservoir of pathogens in this patient
population
meaning do they have bacteria in their
colons as pictured in the top part of
the diagram that can make it into the
bloodstream as pictured in the bottom
part of the diagram and cause an
infection
to address this question fiona wrote a
very straightforward bioinformatic tool
to help us analyze all of these data i
won't go into detail here but i'll just
give you the name of it which is strain
sector and what it does is it enables us
to identify whether the bacteria in the
bloodstream that we're able to identify
is the same as one of the bacteria in
the gut microbiome
when we applied this method on our
patient who had that bloodstream
infection this is actually what her gut
microbiome looked like one day prior to
her infection
this is a stacked bar histogram so on
the y-axis is the relative abundance of
different bacteria so a big chunk of
section means that there's a lot of that
bacteria and a skinny sliver means that
there's less
and what you can see is that
staphylococcus epidermidis which is in
the purple and highlighted by a black
box was actually present in the gut
microbiome of this individual prior to
her infection
now you may say well we've got our
smoking gun staff epi was in the gut
that's the same bug that caused her
infection
but we can't be so fast to conclude that
because staph epidermidis is present on
almost all of us and in fact each one of
us harbors many many many strains
different strains of staph epi and so
while we found stephanie in her gut it
didn't mean that it was the same one
that was in her bloodstream
using fiona's strain sector tool however
we're able to identify how closely
related organisms are to one another and
for patient 13 which is the patient
we're talking about today what we were
able to show was that in the blue box
the stool sample that we had for her was
actually indistinguishable from the
bloodstream isolate in terms of this
bacteria
and this is represented on a
phylogenetic tree which is a way to
measure
evolutionary distance between organisms
when there's a straight line between
them it basically means that they're
identical
now we found that not only staph epi
infections could originate in the gut
we found that many other organisms also
seem to be present in the gut microbiome
prior to patients getting infections
this ranged from organisms like
enterococcus fecium and klebsiella
pneumonia to organisms like e coli and
strep midas
of course we didn't find this for every
organism for a common bloodstream
infection called staph aureus we didn't
in this particular study find any
evidence of gut colonization
taken together what we were able to find
was that about 40 percent of bloodstream
infections in this patient population
are traceable to the gut microbiome
which led us to our next question
which is if pathogens are present in the
gut microbiome of these patients
well how do they get there in the first
place
where do people catch these pathogenic
microbes from
what we know about this patient
population is that they're in the
hospital for a long time they're very
sick
and so we surmise that perhaps patients
were catching these pathogenic microbes
either from the hospital setting or from
one another
and so we inspected whether patient a as
represented on the left could transmit
their microbes to patient b as pictured
on the right
and if this was the case might things
like being in the same room or the same
ward at the same time the risk factors
for this
so to ask and address this question ben
sarah notion a former graduate student
in the lab teamed up with platon a
professor of statistics and genetics and
niaz venai who is the head of our
clinical microbiology group
and what they found was actually
interesting
we studied hundreds of patients who had
been on the same word over the course of
about 15 months
and i'll highlight just a couple of
cases that we thought were interesting
first an overall finding
most patients don't seem to be catching
microbes from their neighbors that much
and so we found evidence of transmission
but it was rare
this is an example of transmission of an
enterococcus fecium which is a pathogen
that can cause bad bloodstream
infections and oftentimes this organism
is quite drug resistant
now on the top part of the diagram once
again you have a stack bar histogram
describing the relative abundance of
different bacteria in that top patient's
microbiome
and you can see that that top patient
was pretty much filled with enterococcus
fecium as highlighted in blue
if you take a look above that diagram
you can see a skinny bar and that bar
indicates when the top patient actually
overlapped with the bottom patient
as a roommate or in the hospital at the
same time
while you can't see it very well what we
found was that the blue organism that is
present in the top individual actually
seems to appear in the bottom individual
albeit at a low relative abundance only
0.4 percent
shortly after the time period where the
two are roommates
suggesting that there was a direct
transmission event between the top
individual and the bottom individual
put another way our bottom patient
actually caught enterococcus cesium
from the top individual in their gut
microbiome
and there the gut microbiome ephesian
could lie in weight until there was an
opportune time to get into the
bloodstream and cause an infection
we not only found this for pathogens
like enterococcus fecine we actually
also found this for good microbes such
as hungatella hathaway
now hungatala hathaway is a commensal
organism that is thought to actually be
very anti-inflammatory and probably
healthy
in our guts
and once again as you can see in this
image we've got one patient on the top
second patient on the bottom
you can see that there was transmission
of a hungatella hathaway eye from the
top patient to the bottom patient
and that happened shortly after they
were roommates
interestingly this bottom patient did
have a hungatella hathaway eye at the
very beginning of this time course and
when we noticed that we thought oh well
maybe these patients just had the same
organism to begin with
however when we compared the hungertella
hathaway that the bottom patient had at
day zero
versus at day 58 we found that those
were totally different
meaning that the original hungatala
hathaway that the bottom patient had had
been replaced by the one that it got
from its roommate
put together what we were able to
demonstrate was that we could use strain
resolved evidence
that gut commensals and pathogens can be
transmitted horizontally between adults
meaning that they can get passed from
adult to adult in this hospital setting
so if patients can catch pathogens
a question then follows if i want to
prevent infections and i know that
infections in the bloodstream often
originate in the gut
and i know that patients can catch these
microbes in their gut
how might we manage patient microbiomes
to prevent acquisition of these
pathogens and eventual outgrowth of them
to answer this question several members
of my lab have worked on a series of
projects where we have tried to modify
the microbiome using techniques that
range from fecal microbiota transplant
to antibiotics to prebiotics
so there are three main ways that you
can change a microbiome in broad brush
strokes one is to use antibiotics that
kill certain bacteria
the next is to use probiotics or live
bacterial therapies a very extreme
version of which is fecal microbiota
transplantation which many of you have
probably heard of where you give the
theses of one individual to another
the third way that you can change the
microbiome that should come as no
surprise to you given that we talked
about it earlier in the seminar is
prebiotics or fibers it turns out that
we can give fibers that selectively feed
certain components of our microbes over
others and this can also be a way to
remodel the gut microbiome
in our first work in this space we
worked on fecal microbiota
transplantation and this was a
collaboration with libby homan's group
at the mass general hospital
while when we do fmt we don't do what's
pictured on the left which is an image
of two people's colons stuck together
what we actually do is something more
like what's pictured on the right
we take feces we filter them we test
people extensively to make sure they
don't have pathogens that we can
transmit and then we can package them
into things like these capsules or
so-called crap souls
patients then take 15 of these pills one
day another 15 of these pills the next
day and that's usually enough to
actually colonize their gut microbiomes
at least in the short term with these
microbes
while i won't go into details of the
findings that we had in this study i'll
summarize it by saying that we found
that the microbes that the donor gives
to the recipient through this fmt
colonize well in the recipient for the
first few weeks
but in the long term they end up getting
washed out by other organisms suggesting
that short-term colonization is actually
quite prevalent but long-term changes in
the microbiome are actually hard to
achieve with a two-time fecal microbiota
transplant
another way to change the microbiota is
actually to use prebiotics as we've
discussed
and tessa anderman along with andrew
rasvani
carried out a prebiotic pilot trial
where we gave a prebiotic in this case
fructooligosaccharide
which you'll remember is a fiber that is
commonly found in plants such as
onions
we gave this fructooligosaccharide to
patients undergoing a transplantation
we did a dose escalation single arm
study 15 patients were enrolled and the
fos or fruit oligosaccharide was
tolerated well
while this was going on tessa collected
stool samples and blood samples from
these patients as well as control
patients who are not receiving the
fructooligosaccharide
while we found no major differences in
the gut microbiome between the
individuals who got the fos and people
who did not
we did find that
fructooligosaccharides were probably
important for producing this type of
small molecule called butyrate
fructooligosaccharides once again are
these complex sugars and bacteria can
metabolize them into tiny little pieces
which are called butyrate short-chain
fatty acids and butyrate had been
demonstrated by others in the field to
actually be very anti-inflammatory
in this particular example butyrate
could ameliorate or improve graft versus
host disease which is an inflammatory
disorder
the way butyrate works is it actually
can trigger
t regulatory cells which are an
inflammation suppressing cell type in
the immune system to proliferate
and so we had surmised that fos might
increase the abundance of t-regs these
anti-inflammatory t cells in the
patients who got it
and indeed we found as is outlined in
the red box that patients who got fos
had more fox p3 cd3 cells which are t
regulatory cells than control patients
so we've talked about probiotics or fmt
we've talked about prebiotics
the other arm of this three-legged stool
is antibiotics
now typically we think of antibiotics as
doing harm to the microbiome
but a series of studies done over the
past approximately five decades have
suggested that giving patients
non-absorbable antibiotics meaning
antibiotics that can act on the
intestine inside of the intestine but
don't get into our bloodstream can
actually improve the outcomes of
patients who are undergoing
hematopoietic cell transplantations
so jen wangbo who is a physician
scientist in boston at boston children's
hospital and chris severin who is a
pediatric hematologist and oncologist in
my lab
teamed up
to do a randomized controlled trial of
this practice of gut decontamination
in pediatric patients undergoing
alogenetic hematopoietic cell
transplantation
what they did was actually give once
again some patients the gut
decontamination and other patients did
not get any so they were the controls
and they looked for differences in the
patient populations
now this was a very small study and
while this did not reach statistical
significance we did find that the
patients who got gut decontamination had
many fewer bloodstream infections than
the patients who did not get the
antibiotics
which suggests that these gut
decontamination antibiotics might be
clearing out some of those pathogens
that we've demonstrated can be present
in the gut microbiomes of these
individuals
chris was further able to demonstrate
that in every case in the non-gut
decontamination arm or though controls
where they had an infection the
infection was traceable back to the gut
microbiome
taken together what we found was that
this is days after transplant on the
x-axis
and the percent of people who had a
bloodstream infection with concomitant
colonization of the gut with that
organism
we see that there is a big difference a
visible difference between those
individuals who had no gut
decontamination versus those who had gut
decontamination which suggests that gut
decontamination may decrease the
incidence of these bloodstream
infections
so coming back to this picture
i hope i've convinced you that we and
others have developed exquisitely
sensitive methods to figure out who's
there in the microbiome
and we know that measuring microbes at
the strain level matters because there
are millions of different strains of for
example an e coli out there in the world
we talked about precision clinical
microbiology in the sequencing era
we talked about how we can track
microbes between patients
and finally
we talked about how we can modify the
microbiome using fecal microbiota
transplants antibiotics and prebiotics
so that's what we've done what are we
doing next i thought i would give you a
bit of a sneak preview into the work
that we're up to now
and as we look to the future we have
become extremely interested in co-opting
microbial communication systems so that
we can precisely manipulate medicine
when we look at this figure part of what
we're trying to do is really zoom in to
the bacterial side of things
and when we zoom in i imagine a scene
like this is going on where you have
wonderful and exciting conversations
going on between bacteria
and not only between bacteria but maybe
also even between bacteria and us
this is actually not so far fetched
we know from previous research that
microbes can use small molecules or
chemicals to talk within species so they
can talk to their own
they can talk between species and
actually also engage in bacterial
warfare killing others off
and they can use these small molecules
to even talk between domains of life
meaning between bacteria and humans
this small molecule collection of
communication signals has been exploited
extensively in what i call nature's
medicine cabinet
many of the drugs that we use in modern
medicine today ranging from the
chemotherapy doxorubicin to the topical
antimicrobial agent bacitracin are
actually derived from bacteria
but while these small molecules or
chemicals have been well mined for their
use in precision medicine
proteins have not been so well mined
proteins however are optimal signaling
biomolecules
they're diverse they're very highly
specific
they're biocompatible and we can
synthesize them scalably
and so the question that we now have in
our lab is mite microbes use small
proteins to communicate
a greatly enabling piece of work that
has allowed us to peer into this new and
exciting realm of micro protein based
communication was carried out by gila
sparrow a former postdoc in the lab
using computational biology approaches
and evolutionary theory she was able to
discover thousands of hidden small
proteins in microbial genomes
in total she discovered about 4 500 new
families
most of these are of unknown function
and about 30 percent of them we predict
are involved in cell cell communication
so as we move forward what we hope to be
able to do is take this blue bacteria on
the left identify small proteins that it
makes like these pink blobs
figure out what host cells or human
cells they communicate with as pictured
in the middle and eventually exploit
this information to be able to treat the
cancers that are pictured on the right
we'd love to be able to understand how
we might
use microbial proteins to regulate human
biology and to improve cancer treatment
to therapy
so taken together our relationship with
our microbes is most certainly
complicated some of the microbes are bad
some of the microbes are good sometimes
it just depends on if they're in the
wrong place at the wrong time
but we have lots of opportunities now
that we have sharp and effective tools
to measure microbes to study how they
impact host health
one of the most important things that we
do in our lab is collaborate broadly
across the world as you heard in the
introduction
and really proud and honored to
collaborate with the h3 africa genomics
consortium to improve the study of
microbiomes and
genomes
all over the world not just in places
where wealthy people live and
researchers happen to resign
and so we've been very fortunate to
collaborate with professor hazelhurst
boki oduwaran and many others
in south africa to actually carry out
some of the first
comprehensive microbiome analyses of
individuals in africa and i'm actually
very excited because our first major
paper on this uh or a set of major
papers on this just came out over the
course of the last year with the most
recent paper coming out two days ago
we're interested in these not only
because of diseases like cancer but as
pictured on the previous slide issues
such as obesity and heart disease have
become of increasing interest not only
in high income countries like the united
states but all over the world including
in south africa
so there our focus has been on obesity
and women and cardiometabolic disorders
soon we actually plan to study menopause
as i mentioned before we're keen to
figure out how microbial therapy might
boost cancer immunotherapy
and i would be remiss to not mention
that we are also very keen to understand
the gut brain axis
focusing on a couple of major diseases
alzheimer's disease and parkinson's
disease
finally i'll just end with a note about
how microbial genomes are interesting
not only because they tell us how
microbes function
but they also are amazing treasure
troves of cool enzymes and machinery
i'm guessing that many of you in the
audience have heard about crispr which
is basically a system the crispr cas9
system is a system that exists in
bacteria to fight off phages which are
viruses that infect bacteria
this entire enzyme system has been
co-opted for genome editing there are
tons of companies in this space and this
type of editing technology has enabled
medical practitioners to fix errors in
people's genomes to try and reverse
diseases
most recently we and a set of
collaborators in the basic bintu and
shoe labs have worked together to
identify a new class of genome editing
enzymes from bacterial genomes
this class had been previously described
in a limited way these are the large
serine recombinases we've been able to
discover thousands of additional
candidates and identified the specific
places where they target in the genome
which might enable us and others to take
large amounts of dna cargo and deliver
them to safe places in the human genome
thereby treating people who have
complicated gene deletion disorders
so we've talked a lot about it i've
talked about a lot of things today
ranging from who's there in our
microbiome to how we measure them how
microbes travel between human bodies and
within a human body to cause problems
and we've touched on how
things are moving in a new direction to
try and better understand microbial
communication so we can co-opt those
machineries to try and improve modern
medicine
there is a lot of promise as i'm sure
you can appreciate and a lot more work
to do
i look forward to hearing your questions
and i just want to end by thanking my
entire lab as i mentioned i'm very
fortunate to work with an incredibly
talented and passionate group of
individuals
our many collaborators
our funding sources
my recent grads and of course all the
patients and people who have
participated in our studies
i look forward to your questions great
thank you so much professor bot for that
presentation that was really fascinating
so for the first question
if a baby elephant is inoculated by
feeding on parent species to acquire the
microbiomes what's the mechanism that a
human infant uses to acquire microbiomes
yeah great question
so it's been demonstrated that infants
actually acquire their first microbes
during birth which means that the
microbiomes of infants foreign by
vaginal delivery are actually quite
different from the microbiomes of in
infants that are born by c-section it's
been demonstrated that in the very very
early part of life infants actually or
by vaginal delivery are colonized with a
lot of vaginal microbes and infants born
by c-section it won't surprise you are
colonized with a lot of skin microbes
over the course of time however infants
probably continue to collect microbes
from their environment
from their mom and dads from the skins
of people around them
you know a great
mentor of mine stan falco who was a
really world famous microbiologist i
used to joke that the world is covered
in a fecal veneer meaning that there are
microbes everywhere that you know are
from the gut microbiome and so there's
probably a little bit of that as well
and so as babies actually
move on in life they acquire microbes
from their environment and there's
actually a very standard process up
along which the microbiome builds which
is actually super fascinating and a
topic in and of itself
that's really interesting thank you
um the next question is when the
microbes that are transferred via fmt
they go away over time is it because the
native microbiome has pathogens in it
that take over or the native microbiome
just resets
this is an excellent question that we
don't exactly know the question the
answer to yet
i would speculate that what happens is
there are micro microbes from the native
microbiome the original recipient
microbiome that are kind of lying in
weight and so they're suppressed to very
low levels and over time they can
actually increase in amount
i also think that people
reacquire probably their microbes from
their environment
i think part of the reason that microbes
the donor microbes go away might be due
to actual warfare which is what you have
described right they're being fought off
by the the recipient microbiome
another reason that they might go away
is because of lifestyle differences so
for example i happen to be vegetarian if
i got a fecal microbiota transplant from
somebody who ate mostly meat
a lot of their microbes would not find a
happy home in me because i wouldn't be
feeding them the right foods and so i
think that also plays a role in figuring
out which microbes might be able to stay
for a longer term versus which end up
getting kicked out
i also think that the question you asked
is very related to the sim previous
question you know we talked about this
very orderly process of microbiome
assembly that happens in infants
and if you think about that really
orderly process like a pyramid if you
take out a piece of the middle of the
pyramid it's really hard to replace it
with a piece that's a different size or
shape and so i think what happens is our
microbes are very dependent on each
other in a complex network and that's
probably also why the introduction of a
few microbes via fmt or probiotics is
unlikely to have long-term effects
unless we keep on giving people those
microbes
great thank you
um the next question is what are some
good ways to improve and protect our gut
health and microbiomes
so there are several things that we can
do to try and improve our gut health and
protect our microbiomes i think one
thing that is incredibly important is
trying to eat a diverse diet in fact
many different diets have been studied
and
many have posited that certain diets are
better for the microbiome than others
i think some of the most convincing data
on this comes from a study that found
that eating more than 30 3-0 different
types of plants in a day in a week
rather is one of the biggest predictors
of microbiome diversity and so i think
keeping a diverse diet is incredibly
important staying hydrated is probably
an important part of this equation
many people do want to take probiotics
or eat fermented foods obviously many
cultures across the world have had long
traditions of fermented foods and i
think that it's advisable
however with probiotics it's hard to
know what you're getting probiotics
aren't regulated the same way
medications that we take are and so you
never know if what's on the label of the
bottle is actually what's in the capsule
that you're taking furthermore as we
mentioned before it's hard to know if
those microbes that you take in
probiotics will really stick or not so i
think some of the best things that one
can do is try to eat a diverse diet to
try to keep relative
a relative diversity of foods on your
plate
to stay well hydrated and to eat the
types of fermented foods that you enjoy
okay thank you um
along those lines
can
knowledge of individual gut microbes
provide a personalized plan for improved
diet and healthy lifestyles
so there are many many groups that are
actually trying to achieve this
objective of taking a look at your
microbiome and then trying to comment on
what might help you achieve a better
microbiome
i look at microbiomes all day long it's
actually my job and i'm also a physician
and i've got to say i don't think the
science is quite there yet that said
there are efforts that are underway both
on the research side of the equation and
also on the industry side of the
equation to try to help people diversify
their microbiomes
i do think as we look to the future we
will be able to better and better
understand the microbiome to understand
what our microbes like to eat and think
about ways that we can feed them
sometimes i like to joke that you know
we're not just eating for ourselves
we're eating for trillions and so you
know knowing who's in our gut
microbiomes and what they like to eat
might help us actually modulate and
modify our microbiomes i can certainly
tell you that one of the reasons i think
fibers are so important is that simple
sugars are actually preferentially
metabolized by most pathogens and so one
way that we can suppress the growth of
pathogens in the gut microbiome is
really to try to limit simple sugars
excellent there is another question um
is there a significant difference in the
health of breastfed babies compared to
the health of formula fed babies because
of the differences in their microbiomes
so this has been extensively studied in
the medical literature in the microbiome
literature while there are differences
in the microbiomes of breastfed and
formula fed babies early on in life it's
unclear whether those changes actually
persist in the long term i mean there's
obviously the intersection area too
there are a lot of babies that are fed
by both breast milk and formula and so
that remains another kind of interesting
area for investigation
i think you know based on the data that
we have right now the best answer i
could probably give is that
there are probably no major long-term
effects there may be some subtle ones
and in the setting where there is
extended formula feeding before the
introduction of solid foods there may be
some consequences in terms of immune
maturation because remember those early
parts of life where the microbiome is
changing and the immune system is
growing and so they're really
influencing one another
i will say one last thought on this is
that while in the united states for
example the practice is not to introduce
complementary foods or solid foods until
around six months of light that is
actually very different in different
countries around the world and so there
are countries where solid foods are
introduced very very early on and so i'd
be very curious to know how that impacts
the growing that microbiome of babies as
well
and the next question is
are there any other foods in addition to
onions that are beneficial for good
bacterial strains
absolutely i think there are basically
any fibrous food is a good choice
jerusalem artichokes have a ton of fiber
you know eating fruits with the skins on
so you know don't get rid of that apple
peel just wash your apple and eat it
um
leafy greens have a lot of fiber as well
and it's interesting all of these
different foods have different types of
fiber
legumes also have a wide variety of
fibers
and so you know lentils have different
fibers from garbanzo beans which have
different fibers from pinto beans and so
you know
exploring a variety of these different
plant-based foods can be extremely
helpful for bringing more fiber into
your diet
and how cleanliness do to covid affect
the microbiome
this has been a topic of a lot of
conversation um you know we have kids
who have been you know in
much more hygienic homes who aren't
interacting with other kids aren't
interacting with almost any other adults
other than their parents
i think the anticipation is that this
will have some impact on the microbiome
if you ask me to guess and i would guess
that the impact is going to be
relatively small just because it's so
difficult to live a totally
clean sterile life you know so long as
you're going out there in the world
you're being exposed to tons of bacteria
you know places like soil for example
are just teeming with bacteria way more
microbes in soil per square or cubic
inch than in our guts and so i think
it's really difficult to limit our
exposures entirely but i do anticipate
that as this is studied in the years to
come there will be subtle changes and
i'm curious to see the impact of this i
think that that'll not only be important
on the gut microbiome side of things but
possibly also on the skin microbiome
side of things and so we'll have to wait
to see i do think on balance though you
know we're always weighing risks and
benefits and i think during a period the
period of time where there was so much
uncertainty
certainly
it was worth the potential risk of
deficits in the microbiome to avoid the
sure risk of potential exposure to covid
for young and unvaccinated children
thank you
so do oncology nutritionists recommend
butyrate for patients with graft versus
host disease
so butyrate itself isn't recommended and
part of the reason it isn't recommended
is it really honestly just stinks
butyrate uh i can't believe i'm gonna
say this on a webinar butyrate smells
like farts and so nobody wants to take
it even mice don't want to eat it um and
that's part of why this workaround has
arisen which is giving people fiber so
that butyrate can be made when the fiber
is metabolized
the other challenge is of course
butyrate is actually a small molecule if
you remember what it looks like tiny
short chain fatty acid so it can also be
absorbed very high in the in the gi
tract which means that it may not get
down to the parts of the intestine where
graph versus host disease is important
uh but absolutely it has been
investigated you know people have
thought about are there ways to
formulate butyrate into like a super
um
old factory contained capsule so people
can take it
but it hasn't quite hit prime time yet
all right thank you um last question
that we have time for today since you
talked about boosting regulatory t cells
i imagine there have been studies also
regarding the microbiome and
inflammatory diseases
um specifically like ulcerative colitis
and crohn's
yeah so there have been extensive
studies on ulcerative colitis and
crohn's disease which are two different
flavors of inflammatory bowel disease
these diseases for those who aren't
familiar are caused by our immune
systems attacking our guts and the two
diseases are slightly different from one
another but actually share some
similarities there have been like i said
extensive studies in this regard a lot
of people have actually postulated that
fecal microbiota transplant might be
helpful in changing the microbiomes of
these individuals to try and increase
regulatory t cell proliferation and
suppress inflammation
that's actually some of the work where
it's been found that
while a fecal microbiota transplantation
might help people for a while the effect
seems to go away and we wonder if our
findings that donor strains don't really
engraft for the long term might be
responsible for this finding and so
there are studies underway with both
fecal microbiota transplant and
probiotics live bacterial therapies to
to give people those therapies on a
routine basis to try and suppress
inflammation
so i anticipate that there will continue
to be exciting research in this realm i
will say from a physician perspective if
we could find a way to find the
molecules that are actually responsible
for
modulating the immune system and doing
much more than just inducing t-reg
proliferation i'd much rather develop
those molecules into medications that we
can give patients
rather than taking the risk of giving
somebody
a fecal microbiota transplant filled
with lots of known and many more unknown
bacteria where i could possibly be
introducing a pathogen and so i would
say the field is really moving in the
direction of thinking about what the
molecules are that the microbes use to
engage in crosstalk and then leveraging
those as potential drug-like compounds
perfect thank you so much i think that's
all the questions that we have
time for today so
we're going to need to wrap up um but if
you'd like to learn more from dr bot and
the rest of the genetics faculty we
encourage you to join our genetics and
genomics program you have more than 90
hours of content to learn from them as
well as access to videos and exercises
to sharpen your skills and a link to the
recording of this session will be
emailed to you soon so feel free to
revisit this content once again thank
you for joining us and we hope you have
a great week
we hope to see you again in future
sessions and thank you so much dr bot
for joining us today this is a great
presentation we appreciate it
thank you very much have a great day
everyone
you